what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Avengers versus X-Men
versus eternals and we are picking up
with the god Celestial having made its
judgment against the Earth and basically
decided that everybody's gotta go and
again this is really cool because it's a
it's a very cynical take on Humanity I
wouldn't go as far as to say that the
real world is a reflection of how it's
being judged here in the comics I would
say that it oftentimes seems like that
but unless you've like traveled the
world and seen what's out there there's
no real way you could actually make a
judgment against the nature of humanity
itself uh but the thing about this is
that in this comic and in this story The
God Celestial in the last video that we
did had examined the real heart of
hearts when it came to individual people
and looked at a combination of how they
see themselves how they see the world
their actions what they truly believe
all those different things and it judged
against humanity because it made the
decision that Humanity just simply made
the world a crappy place because
Humanity in and of itself is is really
self-destructive selfish different
things like that and what the god
Celestial does is looking at Humanity as
it exists in the Marvel Universe then it
looks at Humanity as being a group
whereby there is more negativity than
there is positivity humanity is
inherently worse than it is beneficial
now the funny thing about this is that
to a degree the the god Celestial is not
really judging objectively and this
comes by way of a girl named Jada who
meets with Captain America that Steve
Rogers was one of the first people to be
judged by the god Celestial and in
looking at Steve Rogers basically came
up with this idea or came up with this
argument that you have positioned
yourself you weren't thrust into this
role you positioned yourself as being
kind of the moral focal point of the
superhero Community right you're Captain
America everybody rallies around you you
have failed in your role it's almost to
a degree a kind of meta textual critique
of America here in the real world right
like a Beacon of Hope and light in the
world and a task that we've kind of
failed at and that's the argument that
it creates here with Captain America but
the reality here is it is a skewed
judgment because there comes a point
when Captain America is talking to Jada
who's just a regular person out there
and it's one of those things where we
end up finding out that she had lost her
daughter when she was younger and
literally is just angry at the world
because of it and in fact she's angry at
the people she knows because they
survived where her daughter died now
that's usually a normal reaction when it
comes to like losing someone Close To
You Right losing a parent especially if
you're a parent who's lost a child
you're surrounded by people who survived
and the question you probably find
yourself asking is why are they alive
why did my child have to die why
couldn't one of them have died instead
or something along those lines as if
it's some kind of divine judgment that
says that like somebody's got to die
today and it might as well be your
daughter right like well why couldn't it
be that person over there it's not
logical it's 100 emotional but it's the
nature of people and it's one of the
things where when she has this
conversation with Captain America he's
kind of like but you should be spending
time with your family right we're here
in the final moments of Humanity's
existence you should be spending that
time with your family it's him trying to
inspire fire her and that's where you
really start to realize that the
Judgment of the celestial is a skewed
judgment here because when you look at
Captain America for what he truly is he
is inspiring he is a person that's able
to motivate and drive people to become
better what you end up running into is
basically people who aren't really able
to look at that inspiration and see it
for what it is and find themselves
blinded by their own political views or
their own life experiences or their own
moral compass or whatever it happens to
be that basically keeps them thinking
small and acting small and viewing the
world in relation to themselves now of
course in the midst of this conversation
Nightcrawler simply appears and says Hey
so uh we're basically going to try to
find a way to save the world even though
the world hates us and the world judges
us as mutants ah but do you want to
become a part of it
and so what ends up happening is Captain
America kind of has its realization
where he basically tells Nightcrawler
teleport me to the celestial and when
that happens have Jean Gray use her
telepathic powers to broadcast the
entire situation to the world and what
Captain America says in speaking to this
Celestial is he says I've stood before
tyrants before they've all been so sure
that it's all over they were all as sure
as you are I was there in 1940 and
people thought it was over heroism is
not about strength it's about Not Giving
in and the truth is it's not over as
long as any of us are standing the world
can hear me know this we are all
Avengers now a symbol and avenge now of
course Captain America is annihilated in
front of everybody by the celestial but
the world sees this broadcast and that's
the unifying factor of Captain America
the question then becomes how successful
would we be if we launched a strike
against the the god Celestial itself now
the
eternals chime in and the eternals are
like lest we forget the nature of our
programming if we attack a Celestial
will be overtaken by it right our
programming will take over and will in
turn start attacking you guys it's
exactly what happened before but they
also found a workaround what they ended
up doing was basically kind of lowering
their psychic firewalls right if their
programming is ingrained into their DNA
because in Marvel Comics eternals are
not robots but if they're if their mind
is more or less programmed with this
idea that no Celestial can be harmed in
the presence of an eternal then what
would happen if a powerful enough
telepath were capable of overriding that
that if they lowered their their mental
protection right their mental blocks and
someone like Jean Gray were to seize
control of them and that programming
were to kick in is Jean Gray powerful
enough to override it and the answer to
that question is absolutely she is and
not just Jean Gray the other telepaths
and so what ends up happening here is
that all forms of disagreement are cast
aside by The eternals Who were here as
well as the X-Men and the remaining
Avengers and what this does is it allows
the group to unify now for the telepaths
they seize control of the eternals and
what that does is it allows them to
control the eternals essentially but to
also keep out the programming so it will
allow the eternals to attack the
celestials and when I say the eternals I
mean all of them even the hex right just
these ridiculously huge and Powerful
eternals it allows them to control them
all and so what you end up getting is
this unified force of the Avengers and
the X-Men and the eternals all of whom
launch their attack against the
celestial and it's the funniest thing
because literally this Celestial says
they are Earth's Best hope mortal power
against a star God the buzz of
ballistics cannot hurt me however it
does distract it allows the hex to get
close each one of the Stepford cacus who
are basically clones of Emma Frost each
one of the stuff for Cuckoos drives one
of the soldier heads mother Emma takes
mother region X they are machines
designed to fight Cosmic Predators such
as myself their attack compromises my
counter-attack leading me open for
reposit I am a god appropriately they
unleash hell yet all of this is prologue
the hammer is still to come Earth's
Mightiest strike is one their target is
exposed they are a metaphorical Hammer
the final blow is from one more literal
right the hammer of Thor himself I am
impressed I see so many brought together
but I have already finished my judgment
what God would I be if I backed out now
yes Thor is worthy but the world is not
I make every part of Thor unworthy his
skin slows from his body in revulsion
star brand Burns Phoenix Burns Jean Gray
Burns Exodus Burns phosphorus fast they
are all gone it's basically like a total
Annihilation here this is something that
I want to point out is that these Heroes
getting close enough to this guy odd
Celestial and being close enough to
attack it it was him allowing it to
happen if anything it was actually him
just kind of toying with them allowing
them to believe they could come that
close to Victory allowing them to
believe that they ever even stood a
chance in the first place but the
reality is none of them ever did he
kills all of them all of them are
completely annihilated by the celestial
like we're talking about Carol Danvers
we're talking about Spider-Man right
Thor the whole nine yards the heaviest
hitters in Marvel Comics from a variety
of different places are all being
completely and totally annihilated and
there's nothing they can do to stop this
and so it literally says I will burn the
cities and I will burn the Seas I will
burn the Earth and all creatures of the
Earth the passengers of this ship
represent more wealth than the rest of
the planet combined the experimental
engines prepare to engage sites set on a
new blue-green Eden they think they can
escape my judgment no one of the things
that I also want to point out here is
this is how celestials work so the way
this normally happens right usually it's
erisham the judge that will judge
against the world when hiroshim judges
against the world then another Celestial
will cleanse the planet quite literally
they'll turn it into a burning sender
just floating through space but then the
gardener Celestial will come in and
actually start planting new Seeds of
Life on the world and it'll basically
start to grow again right life will be
able to start all over again and that's
really what the god Celestial is doing
here right it's making this
determination that what it's going to do
is annihilate all life on Earth and then
start allowing Earth to basically start
developing new life and hopefully
Humanity won't screw up again when
Humanity inevitably re-emerges if it
even emerges in its current form and so
that's one of those things where it's
like we don't know exactly how this will
turn out but everything is being
cleansed and sanitized it's all being
completely and totally destroyed the
crazy thing about it is even the god
Celestial tells the Earth it's time to
die and the Earth itself lashes back at
the god Celestial and simply just
refuses to allow itself to be destroyed
but the truth about this is that when it
comes to all these Heroes who have been
annihilated precious few survive
something like five of them made it out
in one piece most everybody else was
completely eradicated but remember the
other problem here is that when the war
between the X-Men and the eternals first
broke out the Jack of Blades had
infiltrated cocoa and in doing that had
destroyed their ability or at least most
of their ability to resurrect anybody
from the dead using the krakowan
resurrection system and so because of
that what you have now is just a handful
of eggs that can be used by the five to
bring back anybody who's died and so the
effort to do this is really confined to
who do we bring back another response of
somebody like Exodus is we have to bring
back Cyclops Cyclops is the field leader
of the X-Men he's the guy that was
literally the one that would take us
into battle take us into conflict right
he's our version of Captain America but
the response of Nightcrawler any even
the response everybody else is no that's
not who the world needs right now the
world does not need like Cyclops the
world does not need him right the other
part of this is that when they had
initially launched their strike against
the celestial they had consulted Destiny
right because remember Destiny can see
the future and the closer to the present
day or the present moment that she's
predicting the more accurate she is
right so if she predicts or says here's
what's going to happen in five minutes
it's gonna be way more accurate than if
she says here's what's supposed to
happen in 500 years but when they
consulted her and they talked to her her
stance was yes your attack on the
celestial can work but only with a few
modifications and so what they did is
they held some of their number back with
the intention of launching yet another
strike force to infiltrate the celestial
now where their initial Strike Force was
done for the purpose of exposing some
kind of weakness that would allow the
superheroes to destroy the celestial
that doesn't work they already know that
fails so they have to have some other
plan in place we don't know the exact
details of it but basically it's Jacob
blades who leads the Strike Team into
the celestial itself the problem with
this is that when they arrive the
celestial as you would expect
immediately picks up on the fact that
they're there even though they have a
cloaking system and it makes perfect
sense right I mean it's very difficult
to fool a Celestial using something like
telepathy or just a basic cloaking
device because celestials are just so
astronomically powerful but in order to
fool the celestial into believing that
Jack of Blades is the only one who's
actually there that what Jack of Blades
does is appear to the celestial and
literally just make some kind of
offhanded remark right like I'll be
seeing you and draws the attention of
the celestial which annihilates Jack but
it seems to lead the celestial to
believe that Jack was the only one who
was there that's actually not the case
but the thing about this is that when
you pick back up with essentially this
Resurrection process the members of the
five who were able to bring people back
there's this debate going on between
Exodus and Nightcrawler that's still
raging right The Stance of Exodus we
have to bring back Cyclops we can't
bring back anybody else but again what
ends up happening is Nightcrawler says
no this is the guy we have to bring back
and the response of Exodus is this is
heresy right you we cannot use it's
against the rules of krakowa to use
these eggs to bring him back it goes
against everything that we have and The
Stance of Nightcrawler is no it simply
just goes against our customs right the
Only Rule that we have when it comes to
humanity is kill no man right do not
start a war between human beings and
like the mutant population but the other
reason why this is so important is
because he says what are Customs if not
just habits that we have that a lot of
people take part in right getting
together on Sunday for dinner is a habit
but it becomes a custom because it's
something that like the entire family
does but the reality is as long as we
live we have to try something new that's
what we do Cyclops is a great leader but
he's not who the earth needs right now
and so using the power of Resurrection
what they end up doing is bringing this
person back and when that happens in one
of the greatest moments in Marvel Comics
Captain America's shield comes smashing
through the mutant Resurrection system
now the question you have to ask here is
this is this Steve Rogers as we knew him
is this Steve Rogers with potential
enhancements if Steve Rogers a guy with
powers now what kind of Captain America
are we looking at here because lest we
forget whenever mutants are resurrected
they're always resurrected based on how
they existed before right meaning like
their minds were backed up and while
Captain America is not a mutant remember
you have Proteus here who's the one
resurrecting people meaning Proteus can
modify the DNA structure of anybody he
resurrects if there was a request that
was made we need to give Captain America
more Powers we need to give him a
combination of all the X-Men's powers or
all the Avengers powers or make him
equal to the celestial in terms of power
presumably Proteus could potentially do
that that's the question you have to ask
here is this just human Captain America
or is it some something more but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace